y
[Música]
en afganistán en continúan las
evacuaciones en medio del desespero de
miles de afganos por abandonar su país
según un funcionario de la otan ya son
más de 18.000 personas las que han
salido desde el aeropuerto internacional
de kabul la organización se comprometió
a redoblar los esfuerzos de evacuación
la canciller alemana angela merkel se
reúne por última vez antes de dejar su
cargo con el presidente ruso vladimir
putin en el kremlin entre los temas está
la llegada del poder del grupo talibán a
afganistán el conflicto ucraniano el
gasoducto nord stream 2 y la crisis en
belarús y además el caso naval y
tendremos ampliación desde la capital
rusa
la ayuda alimentaria extranjera llega
lentamente a más áreas rurales del sur
de haití luego del terremoto de 7.2 que
mató a al menos a dos mil 189 personas
cientos protestan y reclaman asistencia
a medida que la situación se agrava por
el colapso del colapso hospitalario y
cuando queda un número indeterminado de
más cadáveres bajo los escombros
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france24 sierra blanco y
como siempre un gusto acompañarlos
comenzamos en afganistán donde cinco
días después de la toma de kabul por
parte del grupo talibán el caos en el
exterior del aeropuerto de la capital
continúa con miles de afganos intentando
acceder a la terminal mientras se siguen
escuchando disparos al aire para tratar
de contener a esta multitud según un
funcionario de la organización del
tratado de atlántico norte en más de
18.000 personas han salido del país
además la otan se comprometió a redoblar
los esfuerzos de evacuación a medida que
aumentan las críticas al manejo de la
crisis por parte de occidente entretanto
se siguen conociendo denuncias de lo que
los insurgentes continúan buscando en
sus casas opositores y aliados de los
gobiernos occidentales y para
precisamente hablar sobre quiénes son
los líderes del talibán que están al
frente de este nuevo gobierno quiero
saludar en este momento a carlos patiño
profesor titular de la universidad
nacional de colombia experto en temas de
medio oriente profesor gracias por estar
aquí con nosotros en france 24 y
comenzamos hablando
una de las figuras clave del talibán
jesús es un cofundador abdul ghaní
baradar quien tras dirigir la estrategia
política del grupo desde el exilio en
pakistán durante los últimos 20 años de
la invasión estadounidense regresó al
país le preguntó si iba a dar será
entonces el nuevo líder de afganistán y
que otras figuras fuertes e talibán
están en la cúpula gobernante
muy seguramente para dar va a ser la
clave figura clave en el gobierno porque
además es la figura fundamental de la
relación con la agencia de inteligencia
militar de pakistán el isi que es
finalmente el creador de los talibanes
en 1994 fue el conductor militar de los
talibanes en esa primera etapa de
gobierno hasta el inicio de la guerra
con los eeuu y fue quien además iguacú a
la cúpula talibán incluido osama
bin-laden del territorio de afganistán
en ese momento como ya hoy se sabe está
ampliamente documentado y desde 2003
baradar estuvo desde el principio al
lado del mulá omar hasta 2013 en la
confección de toda esta
reconstrucción de los talibanes y
obviamente era esta voz de ninguna
manera escondida o esta voz que no era
visible no tenía cara entonces creo que
ahora finalmente a la figura fundamental
el otro del que hemos visto con claridad
es el vocero jay las hijas que se quizás
el mayor
es mucho más que un portavoz es una
especie de ideólogo clave y el vídeo
logo moderado contemporáneo
aparentemente pero moderado dentro de
los términos de esa versión que los
afganos tienen de la ley islámica aquí
irán desplegando otros nombres distintos
que apenas empezamos a conocer con algún
detalle y aún digamos está por verse
cuáles van a ser realmente los que armen
la gran sur de afganistán que será en
últimas de luz del gran consejo islámico
y que tendrá el papel tanto jurídico
como político y militar para tomar las
últimas decisiones dentro del nuevo
emirato islámico de afganistán hablemos
ahora de ese tipo de moderación es que
usted estaba comentamos porque
comentando porque hemos visto que los
insurgentes ahora con el control del
país están enviando al mundo un mensaje
conciliador y de respeto por los
derechos y las libertades pero puertas
adentro vemos represión asesinatos y
persecución y es apenas el comienzo como
será la relación del talibán con él más
internacional
realmente yo pues soy muy pesimista creo
que la mayoría de los observadores los
cautos son solo fundamente pesimistas en
este supuesto mensaje de moderación
realmente el mensaje de moderación para
poner un ejemplo en el caso de las
mujeres y aquí hay que poner ejemplo
además que es esta presentadora de la
cadena de noticias todo lo de la
presentadora de noticias a quien se le
apareció un talibanes de lunes en la
noche en su programa de noticias y ayer
mostraba ella en su programa en su
cuenta de twitter que había quedado
prácticamente sin trabajo que quedaba
por / volver a aparecer en la televisión
y que incluso temía por su vida esto es
la demostración de lo que en últimas
cuando uno lee ya la vez término de lo
que estaban diciendo es las mujeres
tendrán derecho a educarse y aportar el
'burka' género de ley islámica es decir
no exacto digamos una limitación muy
fuerte de la moderación es si profesor
pero es que seguimos hablando de las
mujeres y ésta sería ya mi última
pregunta porque el talibán habla de un
gobierno inclusivo sobre todo con las
mujeres es que tan real puede ser esto
vamos a ver a las mujeres dentro de la
cúpula de la cúpula gobernante fue
simplemente una frase cuando retomaron
el poder
para mí es puro maquillaje aquí no va a
haber ninguna moderación no habrá este
asunto ya hemos visto también que por
ejemplo desde antier hay una persecución
de los colaboradores de la otan de los
estados occidentales casa por casa sitio
por sitio y hay un aspecto de
prácticamente volver a las viejas
prácticas el amo del supuesto discurso
moderado es básicamente para presentarse
en el mundo pero no es algo efectivo ni
que sea real increíble y obviamente la
mayor preocupación de la reincorporación
del estado islámico desde como este
grupo permita sunita y obviamente esto
va a marcar una limitación muy fuerte
entre empresa mensaje profesor nada
alentador entonces el panorama que
pintan en el talibán en el gobierno en
afganistán gracias por su tiempo por
estar con nosotros en france 24 nosotros
continuamos luego 16 años de relaciones
agridulces entre el jefe del kremlin
vladímir putin y la canciller alemana
angela merkel los líderes finalmente se
encontraron en moscú para una esperada
reunión bilateral donde se van a tratar
temas como la detención del líder
opositor ruso alexéi navalni el
gasoducto nor swing 2 que está casi
terminado a pesar de las quejas de eeuu
de que este proyecto va a suponer un
gran golpe para ucrania
en afganistán como también lo estábamos
hablando con a retomar el poder por
parte del talibán desde la capital rusa
ricardo martina con todos los detalles
angela merkel se reúne con vladimir
putin hoy aquí la que será la última
visita de merkel como canciller de
alemania a rusia una visita que se
produce en el peor momento de las
relaciones entre rusia y alemania- en
rusia la unión europea y entre rusia y
casi todo el mundo occidental desde el
final de la guerra fría sobre la mesa
había un tema principal que es el gas el
suministro de gas ruso a alemania a
través del gasoducto nord stream y por a
través de él a toda europa y las
tensiones que eso había generado con el
ejecutivo de joe biden pero se ha colado
un tema internacional la actualidad
manda y es la crisis en la panista en
esa crisis causada por la salida del
ejército estadounidense de afganistán y
el terremoto político que ello ha
provocado no sólo en afganistán sino en
todos los países de la zona donde rusia
tiene muchos socios como por ejemplo
tayikistán con quien rusia está
realizando ahora mismo maniobras
militares en previsión de que el
escenario de afganistán pudiesen
replicarse en la frontera con tayikistán
putin
no tienen mala relación entre todo pese
a que han mostrado muchas veces sus
diferencias sobre todo en el plano
internacional y muy especialmente lo
tocante a ucrania pero aún así sus
relaciones no son malas recordemos que
putin habla fluidamente alemán un idioma
que ya manejaba cuando trabajaba como
espía en la alemania comunista
y cambiamos totalmente de información en
haití seis días después del terremoto de
7.2 grados de magnitud el nerviosismo de
la población se hace cada vez más
patente en medio de las demoras en la
entrega de las ayudas a los
supervivientes especialmente en las
zonas rurales donde el acceso de los
trabajadores humanitarios está siendo un
desafío con la población demandando la
asistencia y la situación está agravada
por el colapso de las infraestructuras
más de medio millón de personas dependen
de las donaciones internacionales
marinas sardiña nos amplía la
información
sin comida y con unas infraestructuras
devastadas el hambre aumenta las
tensiones en haití las zonas rurales la
ayuda humanitaria internacional llega a
cuentagotas tras el terremoto que acabó
con la vida de más de 2.000 personas y
deja más de 12.000 heridos el
nerviosismo entre la desesperada
población comienza a ser patente ante la
escasez de alimentos para gateway no
tengo trabajo no tengo agua no tengo
comida mi casa quedó destruida no hay
nada en youtube muchos habitantes
denunciaron que grupos pandilleros están
robando a la población los víveres
procedentes de las donaciones
internacionales en esta comuna cercana a
los cayos donde la población sobrevive
en improvisados campamentos la logística
de entrega de insumos se descontroló no
la presencia de efectivos policiales con
chalecos antibalas y casco logró calmar
los ánimos las condiciones para la
distribución están siendo un desafío
para las organizaciones que argumentan
son insuficientes
dsv posan en sangolquí lo daremos a cada
familia 50 kilogramos de alimentos que
es el equivalente para una familia de 5
personas debería durar una vez es una
ayuda muy básica diría que insuficiente
personas tienen enormes necesidades
en medio del colapso hospitalario y de
infraestructura la única planta de
oxígeno medicinal del sur del país quedó
gravemente dañada por el sismo
hay una gran necesidad de oxígeno en
este momento todos los hospitales
nuestros clientes desde el coronavirus
hay mucha demanda la demanda de los
últimos dos meses aumentó más del 200
por ciento y ahora mismo no podemos
producir ni vender oxígeno
a más de medio millón de personas
necesita ayuda humanitaria urgente en
haití seis días después del terremoto
miles siguen al intemperie y el difícil
acceso por el colapso de las
infraestructuras está complicando las
tareas de los trabajadores humanitarios
para llegar a las víctimas real caixa y
el huracán grave que se degradó a
tormenta tropical tras tocar tierra en
la península de yucatán se encuentra ya
en aguas del golfo de méjico y se
aproxima a la costa continental donde
según pronósticos golpeará como huracán
grace el segundo huracán de la temporada
ciclónica en la cuenca atlántica se
encuentra a 105 kilómetros al noreste de
campeche méxico y presenta vientos
máximos sostenidos de 95 kilómetros por
hora las autoridades mexicanas se
mantienen en alerta para mitigar
cualquier daño que pueda causar este
fenómeno natural
hablamos ahora de cuba porque el
departamento del tesoro de eeuu anunció
nuevas sanciones contra tres
funcionarios del gobierno comunista por
considerar que están involucrados en
actos de represión durante las
manifestaciones sociales del pasado mes
de julio entre los recién sancionados se
encontraron roberto negra y andrés
laureano gonzález del ministerio de las
fuerzas armadas revolucionarias y
abelardo jiménez del ministerio del
interior las sanciones bajo la llamada
ley global magnitski prohíbe
transacciones a través del sistema
financiero de eeuu así como el
congelamiento de activos en ese país
entretanto la organización amnistía
internacional sostuvo que el gobierno
cubano criminaliza la protesta pacífica
encarcela y maltrata a personas cubanas
sólo por expresar sus opiniones y nombró
a seis de los detenidos como presos de
conciencia además pidieron su liberación
inmediata
hemos matado a seis personas como presas
de conciencia en un gesto simbólico
hacia los muchos cientos más que
seguramente merecen esta designación y
pedimos libertad inmediata e
incondicional el cuadro de violaciones
de derechos humanos que hemos
documentado en las últimas semanas
apunta a una política de represión
reforzada para recuperar el control y
restablecer una cultura de miedo que se
tan valió el 11 de julio y seguimos con
más información hablemos ahora de los
incendios forestales que continúan
ardiendo en el estado de california en
eeuu el fuego llamado kaldor ubicado al
norte ha destruido al menos 62 mil
hectáreas y continúan las evacuaciones
en el área según los bomberos al menos
86 estructuras han sido destruidas y
casi 6.000 están amenazadas mientras
tanto otro incendio conocido como caché
destruyó unas 50 casas y sobre está
contenido en un
20% y el más grande también de los tres
que está activo es de c's y con una
destrucción hasta el momento de más de
267.000 hectáreas y está contenido en
tan sólo un tren 5 %
y en nuestra región en bolivia los
incendios forestales ya se encuentran en
cuatro áreas protegidas del departamento
de santa cruz y la emergencia forestal
se extiende a 8 municipios según yo ven
acá rosado jefa de la unidad de bomberos
forestales ayer se detectaron 15 puntos
de fuego y desde enero se han atendido
115 emergencias por incendios forestales
que han afectado a más de 280 mil
hectáreas en todo ese departamento
y en información de la pandemia de kobe
19 las autoridades australianas
extendieron el confinamiento en sydney
por cuenta de este coronavirus hasta
finales de septiembre e introdujeron un
toque de queda nocturno en los suburbios
más afectados de la ciudad las
autoridades de nueva gales del sur
anunciaron que los 5 millones de
residentes de la ciudad deben usar las
mascarillas inmediatamente al salir de
sus hogares excepto cuando habrá un
ejercicio que está actividad además se
ha limitado a una hora al día
y de esta manera llegamos al final del
informativo en france 24 continuan con
nosotros buen día para todos
[Música]